okay so uh let me uh start by this
picture here
uh
which i drew a little break so i could
try to get it right um so the question
is is what is what does this represent
and um so for a lot of people in the
audience um they might say right away
that oh this is this is one of the first
things that's drawn
to describe the mira network
okay
but there's another possibility
is a waylet
decomposition
and the third thing is a holographic
mapping
a holographic mapping
illustrating
the ads cft correspondence
and so the answer is that this
this sort of mapping applies or this
sort of diagram applies to all three
and so it's very interesting
uh connection between these areas
and uh one that hasn't been
appreciated too much before
and uh the the you can draw the same
diagram for each of these areas but the
the way you talk about it and the
systems that they're applied to
are quite different so for instance when
we're talking about
the mira network
you know we tend to talk about using
this to satisfy
log corrections
to the area law
um so different ways of of having a
finite bond dimension that
gives you log corrections with the
length of the system
you talk about the
disentanglers
removing
short range entanglement
okay so here's a disentangler
um
and you talk about uh trying to set up a
renormalization group transformation
that can exhibit scale and variance with
a
tensor network
okay in
the wavelet decomposition language we
talk about quite different things so we
talk about a
sort of compromise between real space
and k space
we talk about things like completeness
and basis sets
uh
let's see we talk about sort of the uh
uncertainty principle in the presence of
orthogonality
so
the wavelet stuff i'm going to
it's going to be the focus of my talk
because that's sort of the area that's
probably
familiar familiar to most people so i'm
going to focus on this uh frank yeah
so is that
when you talk about breakfast is there a
ton of structure there or is that the
difference that's what i'm going to talk
about
yeah
so so people i think for the most part
have not appreciated
this uh
this sort of connection with wavelets
wavelets are a thing that i've thought
about quite a bit because i have a sort
of computational orientation
and so i've thought about things like
what's the best way to do the quantum
mechanics for a many electron system uh
going back to the continuum and using
basis sets
and so wavelets have a clear connection
to making basis sets that are used to
set up your quantum system not taking it
as a lattice that's given but going back
and representing it uh with some
uh basis that that represents the
continuum and so i thought about
wavelets for a long time in terms of how
you how can you set up this problem
better from a computational point of
view
uh
and uh so from that point of view this
sort of connection to mira sort of came
along
um at some point and so that's mostly
what i'm going to be talking about um
but uh
uh let's let me go on the uh
the holographic mapping
what you talk about here
is
sort of the geometry
and defining distances
and i didn't realize this connection
until recently when i saw a pre-print of
shaolin cheese work and so xiao lang is
going to be talking about this and so
you can think about uh
what i'm not going to say too much of
about
the
holography except sort of illustrate a
little bit about how the diagrams
relate to this but but you can think of
it as a bit of a warm-up
for later talks i don't know how brian
swingle's talk will relate to what i'm
saying but
a warm-up where i'm going to be talking
about the sort of simplest point of view
um the wavelet point of view which is
really quantum mechanics of a single
particle in 1d
which we think we all
understand pretty well i hope
at least i feel like i can understand
that part a lot better than more
abstract things so i'm going to try to
uh relate these complicated things back
to this simple
um okay
so
let me
uh
so let me start in on this connection
between
uh mira's and
wavelet decomposition and so i'm going
to switch over now to just talking about
looking at
1d
single particle
quantum mechanics
okay and so i can think of 1d single
particle quantum mechanics both in the
continuum
and i can think of a grid so let me
draw the grid representation
and so the grid you could just think of
you know you're trying to solve this on
the computer and you set up a grid and
you write down a discrete kinetic energy
and here's
the uh hamiltonian with just the kinetic
energy
um so let's first first write down
just the
sort of hubbard type representation
some on i with a
t
c dagger i c i plus one plus
permission conjugate
okay but if i go to just a single
particle first quantized picture
i'll be thinking about this
as a matrix
with zeros
and along the diagonal
and
minus ts
on the off diagonal
and so i can think about diagonalizing
that matrix
right
i don't even have to worry about that
because i'm never going to have two
particles
so
uh
so here's this uh hamiltonian and so
suppose we want to apply some of these
uh sort of uh
the framework that we we think about in
terms of dmrg or or
uh tensor networks
to this single particle uh hamiltonian
and suppose we want to work in this
matrix
formulation first quantize the first
thing that you sort of have to think
about a little bit is how do you even do
a schmidt decomposition in terms of just
a psi of x
and so let's talk about that
okay so uh we're going to think of a
wave function a single particle wave
function psi
as sum on i one to n n is the number of
sites in the system
some coefficients psi sub i
c dagger i
zero
okay so in order to do the schmidt d
composition you need to sort of go
briefly out of the
first quantize notation where you always
have one particle and include the vacuum
also and the point is that if you split
the system
in two
the particle is either on the left or
the right so the particles on the right
you need the state for the vacuum on the
left
so uh it's going to be a representation
that
in say matrix product states has m
equals two
and uh the first state will just be this
vacuum piece
uh and then we can lump together the
other piece here with one particle so
say this goes from one to l
as some i equals one to l
psi i c dagger i zero
and i can call that state l
so uh
so these
are sufficient to represent the wave
function in sort of this slightly many
particle framework over here you have
zero and you have a similar thing
r
on the right that sums over the wave
function coefficients on the right
okay and then you can write the wave
function now
as
the vacuum say for the left part
and the right state
plus the left state
and then the vacuum for the right part
and from this you can write down the
schmidt decomposition right away
you can put this into a matrix form
where you have zero
and then all if you want to write out
all the possible one particle states you
can put side one here psi2
etc these are all the two particle
states
so we'll leave those zero
and then along here we have the states
on the right side
l plus one
okay and so we can form a reduced
density matrix for the left-hand side
and we get a row
which is essentially just
well there's a zero part
and then there's a
l
across
l here
okay
so so this is how we can do the uh
schmidt decomposition the key thing is
that you get just this outer product of
the vector l on the other side and so
it's the eigenvectors
of the density matrix here are well
there's always the vacuum part that just
sort of goes along to make the trace of
rho equal to one but it's really just oh
and i left off the this zero is not
quite right it's really the
normalization
of the right hand part
so this gives the probability
that the particle is on the right sorry
about that
yeah so in general you feel the
separation two two part
so each part may have a zero or one
particle
if the both parts have a zero one
particle then at the end you may have a
two particle states which is not
included in your b right at the
beginning right so
uh i can
just imagine that i'm setting up
something that could include two
particles but then i'm using it to
represent a state that doesn't have two
particles and then this is the structure
that you guys see and so this piece over
here has zero in and so i'm left and
then once i do that i can go back and
just sort of go back to uh
the world of matrices and i see that my
matrices
uh if i just have one state i do this
outer product of this i see
the projection of the state into the
block that i'm looking at
okay so if i have a wave function
now going back to single particle
language and here's
psi of x
okay and i make a block that i want to
do a schmidt decomposition with respect
to
then i take this little piece of wave
function
like that
and that's actually the schmidt
vector there's just one
that i need to worry about aside from
this vacuum
and so here's a schmidt steam
okay so
the
uh
one of the key features of this
so if you think about doing dmrg
in this sort of single particle language
what you end up with is
you have blocks
and you
you sort of iterately iteratively
converge to just the right part of the
wave function for each block
such that you sum them all together and
they all fit together precisely
to
the exact the exact weight function that
you want
so it can work very nicely
you know you can make a single particle
dmrg and you can let it iterate and
treat it as a numerical method for
solving a
matrix problem
but it has
this pathology in the representation
that when you go to the edge of the
block
it you you it has a discontinuity
and you don't necessarily notice it at
first because your block only has
the part where it's non-zero
but if you think about how it fits
together there are kinetic energy pieces
that come in your hamiltonian from
connecting this block with the next one
and those kinetic energy pieces if you
try to go to a grid size that
goes to zero say your grid spacing
is a
then there are kinetic energy terms that
come in as one over a
once you have this sort of
residual effect of the bridge grid that
you started with sort of connecting
these different blocks
uh another way to put it is that you
have all energy scales
built into the dmrg
type of structure
and it prevents you from really thinking
of scale and variance where as you
renormalize you go
to
a system where all the length scales
have have been reduced by some factor
okay
so
the question is is there something that
one can do
to get rid of this problem of having
these sharp edges and the wavelet
approach one way of thinking about it is
it's a way of introducing smoothed out
edges
so that
you have a representation that doesn't
have this this problem
so just like dmrg
can work pretty well for systems
that are critical power law decay the
the extra log in the entanglement uh
isn't necessarily going to kill off the
dmrg for some sort of reasonable system
size and you can do a good job and try
to do finance size scaling but trying to
translate that to truly infinite systems
you get this problem so we're we're
trying to
see how in this single particle language
we can
deal with this issue
and it'll turn out that it connects back
to the sort of more general thing that
you think about with the mirror network
okay so now let me give you an
introduction
to the way i think about
wavelets
sort of from the very beginning we'll
see how this connects
okay so i like to think of wavelets as
something
that you use as a basis set for doing
quantum mechanics in long deep
okay so let's imagine
that i have a grid
and
i'm going to i could think of doing the
quantum mechanics on this grid but
instead i'm going to say no the grid
really represents the coefficient of
of a little basis function set on that
site
and so let me draw what these things
might look like
here's one of these little wavelet
functions
and so you have one of these functions
at every site
okay and uh so you could make a basis
set out of this and if these functions
have
uh
nice enough properties in terms of
completeness and we'd like to make them
orthogonal then it gives you a nice way
of setting up a numerical quantum
mechanics problem
okay but we're going to think about
doing this
and
trying to implement a renormalization
group transformation
that takes us to a larger length scale
so
let me
i should have drawn this one lower but
let me try to draw these functions
at
so this is length scale a and here's 2a
and i'm going to try to make
these functions with twice the length
scale and think about something that
that involves a mapping between those
sorry did you go over again
i didn't understand
how we're supposed to picture this uh
wave function
the lattice
yeah so so i if i have a wave function
that looks like this
you can say that the c dagger i instead
of creating an electron say on one grid
point it creates an electron
in
a function that
a state that looks like that little
orthogonal function sitting on that
lattice site
and as long as those are orthogonal then
you have
uh
you know the the the
commutation relations and everything
work the same and i can describe my
quantum mechanics this way
does that
does that
there must be something i
haven't quite understood so
there's a space here and this is a
function weight so so
we even go step back from that so the
function is defined
where
uh so i'm looking at just psi of x
and x is a continuous variable
so i'm trying to go now to the continuum
but i'm only going to look at you know
the high frequency parts are suppressed
by the kinetic energy so i'm going to
assume that there's just low frequency
parts and so i can have a representation
with a
sort of reduced number of degrees of
freedom
that is spanned by this set of functions
ignore the dots completely the the dots
will simply represent the centers of the
functions so i'll have a single function
s of x
that
defines this basis and then i'll have a
set of basis functions
s of x minus j
where j takes on integer values or
multiples of k
and uh this is the actual basis
i thought you also needed
scale diversity yeah so there's so
there's a scale
so this uh so let's let's make this a
little bit better let's do s
of x over a
minus j
and then i won't worry about the
normalization
if you take a to c or you will get a
little receiving
yeah yeah so you can think of these
these functions that i'm writing down
here uh when you construct them well
they actually make very good
approximations to delta functions
but the the
basis says only if you
also
also change data
yeah
so i can think of a particular problem
which has some sort of
cutoff in the pieces of the hamiltonian
that access the high k states and so
there will be some natural grid spacing
that i can take as my starting
grid spacing
and i'll say that's a good enough
approximation for the continuum
and when you're doing that you have to
worry about the completeness of these
functions how they scale there's a
number of issues that are sort of the
key
to thinking about
how wavelets work in the wavelet
language but we won't deal too much with
those
so then
start with that as a starting point then
i'm going to think of going
to
suppose i try try to implement some
renormalization group structure that
maps it on
to
a description with spacing 2a all the
functions are twice as big
and uh i can think of some normalization
group transformation that takes me from
the space of a to the space of 2a
now i'm going to think about the
wavelets though as a renormalization
group transformation on the functions
themselves
so i'm going to say
the functions at the next scale
i'm not going to say at first that they
are the same as the functions
at the shorter length scale i'm going to
say that they're the linear combination
of those functions okay so
i'm going to assign a level so i'm going
to call this
level
l
and this is level
l plus one
and i'm going to say that
s of l s l of x
is root two
sum on k
c k s l plus 1
of 2 x minus k
where here i've taken the scale factor a
equal to 1
for the uh
uh
or for l
okay so this
is uh sort of writing
this function at uh
i'm sorry steve yeah so just just to
clarify right now it's just a single
part yes and so is it this is just
preliminary to where you want it or is
it or just to orient us
okay so what i'm trying to do is
uh
talk about this part of single particle
quantum mechanics
and writing basis functions and gives
you wavelets
that is you know really really just as a
very simple thing because it's one
particle but
it has these connections to much more
complicated things but so the idea is
that we want to try to really understand
how all this works in one particle
language this is this was sort of the
key
uh
the key progress that led to the
development of dmrg
sort of take a renormalization group
uh real space and say well this doesn't
work why doesn't it work why do we try
to understand it for a single particle
and uh it turned out that that
that wasn't you know wilson wasn't able
to find the way uh
to really solve that problem
uh
or in the even of the single particle
language so these single particle
languages are can be very useful
and we can really understand them in
more detail so that's what i'm trying to
get to here and then i'll worry about
the connections
uh to more complicated things a little
bit later on yeah so it seems
that like in this single particle model
that single particle can be anywhere
like on the line right whereas like in
the spin glass model the particles are
fixed
to
certain points right
so it seems at least on the surface or
that there is no connection but so
you're saying that nevertheless there is
some yeah okay so if you're if you're
used to thinking of spin models
um
you know the
of course spin models we think
and then spatter physics says them
arising from electrons and in local
orbitals and so there's that sort of
connection
there are other connections that talk
about spin models when you have say one
spin that's flipped relative to a
polarized background
but the
but the actual spin degree problems are
are much more complicated than what i'm
talking about
okay
okay so this uh gives a
uh a definite this is the the basic uh
relationship between the functions at
the smaller length scale to the
functions at the larger length scale and
it's all just purely uh functions in one
dimension
and this is sort of the first equation
that you get in say something like this
in say the numerical recipes treatment
of uh wavelets
so the simplest so the the
transformation that takes you from these
functions here up to this function here
there
um are defined by these coefficients ck
and uh
the uh
function well the subscripts l on these
s's now these are different functions s
yes
so
so
eventually i'm going to get to where
i'll only look at a fixed point function
and so that the functions at sl and sl
plus one except for a scale change are
the same function
but more generally you can talk about
the functions as just starting with some
arbitrary function
at the fine scale
and then doing their normalization group
transformation
to get functions at the larger scales
and i'm defining my normalization group
transformation
by this set of coefficients c sub k
that will have a fixed point and
and when people talk about
wavelets and scaling functions from a
wavelet transformation it's really the
fixed point determined by a set of c sub
k's and then you say what's what are the
ideal choices of c sub k's
that give me
nice functions to use for various
properties such as having
optimal localization in both real space
and momentum space with no funny
artifacts and with completeness
okay
so
so basically we have some linear
combination of these uh
short scale functions that makes a large
scale function and the simplest sort of
example of this uh often the most useful
ones that have a finite set of season
case so there's something called a har
wavelet transformation
the transformed
that has c zero
equal one over root two
and c one equals
one over root two and so it only has two
non-zero coefficients and it just sums
up
two local functions
uh
to make the function on the next scale
and you can imagine that if you sum up
just two local functions with zero
coefficients it'll tend to be flatter
than the original function and look like
a little box function and then the fixed
point
will turn out to look just to be just a
box
like that
okay this is
sort of the simplest
thing in the weightlift family family
and it doesn't have very nice properties
because it has these discontinued
continuous edges
okay but now let me introduce a
uh
sort of tensor network style diagram
sorry so the fixed point just means
by that equations
yes
so
uh
basically stick in
sl equals sl plus one
so the the har is it's been a long time
it's not uh it's just a sort of example
of the easiest thing you can do
okay but if we look at there's a diagram
that we can describe here
a tree diagram
it looks like this okay so here's c0 and
c1 c0 and c1 c0 and c1
okay so when we
look at
so here we have
the set of functions that say sl
and then we form the set of functions at
the higher level
l plus one
by taking the specific linear
combinations
of each pair of functions
like this
so
so we think of a diagram here where this
little unit here
just represents
c0 c1
and it takes the specific linear
combination
of
these two functions so when we draw
these diagrams for wavelets we're no
longer thinking of the
structure of our space as being a
product space we're thinking of it as
being a direct sum space
and so we we think of
just psi
sub i psi one just sort of living on the
bottom here
like this
okay then after we do this
transformation we can
write a reduced description of this that
has say a psi prime
one it's like prime two
sorry prime three etc
and uh
uh so another
so it looks like all of these have the
dimension of each of these bonds in the
first quantized language is m equals one
so if you do a mirror if you do a in a
product space
uh n equals one it's a completely
trivial
uh
diagram but if you do it in this direct
sum space it just has the sort of
interpretation in terms of
single particle quantum mechanics
and then uh we can
think about
face what's going to be crucial is
something that i'll draw is this and
this is going to be
down here are going to be the rows
and here's the columns and this is going
to be
a
2 by 2 matrix which
i'll make normally have unitary
so cosine theta
sine theta
cosine theta and minus sine theta
okay so within
the space of single particle functions
living on two sites here's the most
general unitary operation it doesn't
appear in this network yet
but i'll come to that later
so so far the network has just
transformed from
this level l descriptions up to l plus
one and then if i continue this to
higher levels
it makes a tree
and eventually you get a description of
this function in terms of just sort of
one
uh
one function at the top which is uh just
described in this case there's no
degrees of freedom so it would just be
described by
uh the structure of these c0 and c1
okay
so i'm trying to at this
so for so these functions are called
scaling functions and what i'm going to
do next is introduce the wavelet
the scaling function is designed to
capture the low energy low frequency
part of these functions
and then what's left over is the
wavelength
and they're supposed to be orthogonal
okay so so
uh naturally if i only allow the
coefficients to live on two sites then i
choose them equally weighted to get the
best low frequency part
okay so now the
wavelet
is
a different function that's defined with
a
expression like this
so wl
of x
is root two
sum on k
c tilde k
s l plus one
of two x
minus k
let's see do i have the uh
i think i have the uh l and l plus one
backwards let's see no no sorry
i've got it labeled the way i want right
here
okay so i i not sure if i've mixed up
which one's the larger scale but i'm
gonna use that
okay so uh this c tilde sub k
is c of 1 minus k
minus 1 to the k
okay so this is
almost always the choice that's made for
c tilde k and what this does is it makes
the
the function wl orthogonal to the
function
sl
so if you calculate
wl
of
x s l of x
okay
and uh we can
look at this either for
um
this l being the same as that album the
first thing is just to take the same one
and uh make this transformation
orthogonal then you find
that this is equal to zero
by this choice
and that's a simple thing to work out
but i'll
skip it
okay so what the wave functions what
these wavelets look like
just to give you a feel
is
uh if you if you go to the more so this
this equation
applies in general even if the number of
coefficients
is a lot is bigger than this so this is
the simplest thing but normally we might
have 10 or 20 non-zero coefficients
what the wavelets sort of typically look
like
is here's
an s of x
and a wavelet
will tend to look like
something like that
so uh for instance the
integral of the wavelet is
always zero
and uh it's guaranteed to be orthogonal
to this they tend to be shifted
by
half a spacing relative to the
wavelet
to the scaling function
and so that's a wavelength so if you
if you introduce the wavelets uh
you can
modify your
tree diagram to include the wavelets and
all of a sudden it's not truncating
anything at all
so
so first of all you can
so the let me say what the fixed point
is
okay so the fixed point
is only applied to the function
s
you say
s l equals s l plus one
so in other words if you start this
iteration with a
sufficiently
complete and broad
function
of and then
for your starting function and then go
up to larger and larger scales uh
generally you'll
converge to a fixed point and that will
correspond to s l equals
l plus one and maybe it looks something
like this function
then the wavelet function is defined in
terms of that fixed point so you have s
of x
is root 2
sum on k c k
s of 2x minus k
and then w of x
is defined in terms of the s of k's
as root 2 sum on k
c tilde k s of 2 x minus k
okay so the fixed point is only done on
the scaling function then at each stage
you take the piece that you would have
thrown away in the normalization group
transformation and you take this
orthogonal piece and you make use that's
the wave the wavelength
okay so if we have this tree diagram but
then we pay attention to what the
wavelets are doing
the wavelets
so the c tilde k is this
just one microscope
also in the case when k goes to
yes yes so
we can
write this out uh you know it's just
like in the in the case of
uh a dimension two set of c's you're
just swapping it and putting in a minus
sign the neat little trick here is that
it works if you do it this way
for an arbitrarily long
vector you can just work it out
all right can you say that the c k and
the c tilde k would be your cardinal
vectors
yes
yes define them think of them as
running over the infinite set of values
and but being mostly zero in most places
and then use this and then you get two
orthogonal vectors
and so then so you can just show that
that's uh
orthogonal
okay so
the wavelet here is designed to pick up
the piece that was thrown away in the
scale in this rg transformation so we
can write it as
an extra piece
that comes off here
and so up here this guy
describes the scaling function and this
is the wavelet
and if you do that
then these
uh
let's see
the uh little
elements of the diagram
are just these matrices
so
this guy here
we define as c s minus s c
where c is the cosine of theta
and this is the sine of theta
okay so uh what what we're doing here
when we
if we draw this diagram then we say
we're only interested in
one of the
uh pieces of it so for the part that
goes up to the next scale we're only
taking the low frequency part and in
this diagram that's the right hand line
so i sort of
tie off this guy so it doesn't come in
and then i just have
a diagram that
only has one vector at each stage
okay so in this language what we have is
a little unitary matrix and in the
matrix language
our
one row of this tensor network
has actually looked like
a set of two by two
matrices applied to our vector so the
transformation representing
a whole row of these or a whole row of
these guys
looks like these little
c s minus s c where all the thetas are
taken to be the same
and what's the rule
sorry t to the angle
yes okay so the
uh the angle theta now is defining
our it generates our wavelet transform
coefficients so you can do thing two
things one is if you if someone else is
has chosen wavelet uh coefficients that
have particularly nice properties then
you can back out
the angle from the choice or you can go
the other way and say i can define a
broad family of wavelet transformations
based on the angles theta and it turns
out that the angles theta are a
particularly compact representation
of wavelets that you know as far as we
know
um the wavelength community doesn't
really appreciate that you can just
define these wavelets in terms of um
sets of little gates with one angle
and then uh i'll get to them
you know to define wavelets more
generally
we're going to put
shifted gates on top of these and you'll
have a set of angles that define an
orthogonal wavelet with sort of very
broad generality as far as we can tell
these you know if you do google
uh
so so glenn evenly has been playing
around with some of this
with me and if you do if you take the
simplest wavelet and you
calculate what the theta angles have to
be to generate that wavelet
and you google search
for just those numerical values you
don't find anything
so that's an argument that uh this
little
network sort of description this little
diagram description of wavelet
generation doesn't
seem to be known
it's a funny sort of way of doing things
okay so
the let me say a little bit about more
uh
so
the the case where
okay
so suppose we have
a uh
wavelet with
four seeds
and the most famous wavelet is actually
one of these types it's called the
velvet shade
so there's a double shear wave like e4
that has coefficients
a vector of c's is one 8
1 minus root 3
3 minus root 3
3 plus root 3
and 1 plus root 3
describing c minus 1 up to c 2.
so this particular wavelet is sort of
the first type that gets rid of the
discontinuity in the fixed point so the
fixed point for this first example
looks like that
this function
generated by this
has no discontinuities although it sort
of looks like a fractional fractal sort
of shape and you've probably seen lots
of this let me see if i can
it looks something like that with little
uh slope
uh
uh sort of bad behavior at the slope
when you go to a fixed point
okay but uh so suppose we want to look
at this uh wavelet transform
of uh defined by these functions and say
what is the
network that represents that
well
because the the c's stick out
four spaces
uh but
the uh
wavelets are
only spaced apart
two spaces they overlap
you can get something that looks like
this
uh but then you have to have another one
that looks like this
okay so the tensor network diagram in
terms of directly writing down these c's
when you make them longer doesn't look
so nice
okay
yeah
so that's that's the shape of
aren't there four
can you say they're four c's does that
mean they're four different functions or
is it one function shifted
one function is shifted
yeah so so all i'm saying is that
the in order to go the mapping to the
the larger scale level you add up pieces
of four different wave functions
same function
there's only one function at each level
and then at the fixed point there's only
one scale function overall
and the formula that's compact support
right i mean this is c drops
right otherwise the shannon one we were
already quite nice
right so this this
this you get it still has compact
support in space
it has better behavior and momentum
space but still not very good behavior
in momentum space
okay so you can
generate this so you have to see us
see right
right now
uh c tilde was the thing that was
describing the wavelength yeah okay so
that's this is
i think
okay so you see i don't understand your
picture why did you draw this other
thing on top of it
right so the if you if you try directly
to make
so you say
what
how do you generate each wavelet
uh
out of the guys beneath it so in this
diagram if i want to generate this one
it it
comes from these four functions
okay and this guy comes from here over
from these four functions but there's
another one in the middle
that comes from functions that overlap
so it doesn't fit in very well with uh
you know this
and somehow you want these the functions
here so there's this guy comes up here
and this is our tunnel to the other two
ones and they're orthogonal but it's not
apparent from the diagram it's an
awkward construction when viewed this
way
okay but if we go over
to this mirror type network
it arises more naturally
okay so we actually construct this
this guy
as
as this um
extra little piece of the mira
network so when we do we think of
starting with functions that live
locally on one site for the most part
and then we apply this little unitary to
the functions what does that unitary do
it smears out those functions over the
two sites
and so if we might start out with
these states look like that
or
and that or
that
but we're going to smear them out a
little bit with this cosine sine and so
that they look like
this
and
uh sorry
this
so the cs and minus sc okay so that's
gonna do a unitary transformation
so that when we access this guy here we
get we're accessing a function that's a
little bit smeared out
and uh so if we
let's
uh so then we take these two functions
so the this is guaranteed to keep
your transformation unitary
okay and then we apply this uh which is
an isometry and and it keeps
the properties of the system or we can
keep track of the wavelet and then this
is just a unitary transformation
uh
so the question is you know in sort of
thinking about
one particle language
what are we trying to do with this
so if we chose theta equal to zero it
does nothing we choose theta equal to 45
degrees
it goes completely to a sort of k space
representation
like that
and uh
what you want to do with these is spare
things out a little bit but sort of keep
a compromise between case space and real
space
and so for instance if you do theta
equals 30 degrees
you get something that looks like this
that sort of
smears out the functions
gets rid of
the sort of edge discontinuity but still
keeps them relatively local
so it turns out
that
if you
so
there's
um this representation can generate this
uh sort of wave function quite nicely so
if you uh choose it turns out that the
optimal the choice that gives you this
uh special d4 wavelet is just theta
equals 30 degrees
and then
the
theta prime
i can take the next level as defined by
a c prime and an s prime
and there's a theta that generates that
and that's equal to the tangent inverse
of cosine theta
minus sine theta
over cosine theta plus sine theta
and this condition
guarantees that if the
the
scaling function represents
a constant function
okay so this touches on completeness so
when you're you're talking about
wavelets uh there's a nice way to think
about uh the completeness of the
functions so we think about the
completeness of the functions as if you
take
the full set of functions at one level
can you represent a polynomial to a
given order exactly
and so we talk about polynomial
completeness and uh so the d4 generates
this these this combination of functions
will set any uh will represent any
linear function exactly
so it has
completeness through constant functions
and um
uh x
okay so this particular choice will
generate
uh with these two angles this uh d4
wavelet
if you want to
go
so the simplest sort of mirror network
in 1d is the one i've drawn there and
there are various elaborations but the
ones that take you up to
that represent uh
wavelets at higher and higher
uh
number of seas
just have more
levels of these unitary gates so if i do
this
okay do another level
and i can keep going
and do more and more levels
okay and then you look in in mirror we
talk about sort of the causality
uh cone
and the same thing applies here
for
the wavelets so up here are these sets
of wavelets and scaling functions
say this one is a scaling function
so if you set all of these to zero
and you set the one here you'll sort of
map out how far the wavelet goes and
you'll get a function that's defined
on
these set of sort of lower level
functions and you can make them extend
now arbitrarily far
okay so this uh suggests sort of the
first sort of insight that you might
transfer back
from
uh
from this sort of wavelet thing over to
thinking about how to make miracle
networks
is well maybe we should be thinking
about
multiple levels
of these disentangler dates
to sort of smooth things out further so
when you do it at the just the lowest
level the standard
mira type
diagram
if you translate to what the fixed point
looks like in real space it still isn't
so well behaved it's very nicely compact
in
space but it
is
still has in case space with lots of
singularity so if you allow
the function to spread out more you can
get better behavior
okay
so let me say just a little bit
uh
about
this
holography connection
okay so uh what you'll
hear later on in the conference is that
if we look at this diagram
and we think about
the degrees of freedom so this
first of all this diagram represents a
unitary transformation
it's a unitary transformation starting
from
these degrees of freedom
and it re-represents something
in terms of
all of these
little degrees of freedom that stick out
here
uh
so you can think about this as a mapping
from something in one dimension up to
this two-dimensional thing
where
the
uh distance
is doing something funny
and uh
so basically the distance scale is sort
of scrunching up and we can think of
this
uh
distance this direction here is going up
in scale
and so
people like brian swingle have been
talking about this and and uh he'll talk
later in the conference and uh i don't
know how
it'll connect exactly to what i'm saying
but this sort of picture
of mapping from
uh here a one-dimensional system to
something with an extra uh uh
geometrical dimension that those are
scaling this is this connection to a
holographic mapping
and uh so you can
think of this
uh stuff that this simple stuff that i'm
doing with wavelets is sort of a a way
to get
maybe some intuition about these uh
these more complicated uh things to
think about
okay so
let's see
okay so the key thing that i want to get
out of this
is
what can we think about in terms of this
specific so wavelets are a very big deal
in numerical analysis um
you know they produce surprising results
that surprise the field and uh they've
been very useful as a practical tool
so now we have this connection with this
practical tool to some of the uh tensor
network things that we've been thinking
about and so the key thing that we want
to try to get out of this is some sort
of insight
into
how might we do
tensor networks better by thinking about
this
okay so that's